il est 4 heures cécile et brenda sortent
du lycée elles ne sont pas toutes les
deux étudiantes cécile qui est porteuse
d'un handicap moteur prépare son bts
comptabilité et brenda et son assistante
de vie sociale falco le chien
d'assistance de cécile est de la partie
brenda est au volant
direction la maison cécile est
tétraplégique
un handicap qui s'est déclarée à la
petite enfance elle nécessite un
accompagnement quasi permanent pour
effectuer les gestes du quotidien
pour l'école les loisirs la toilette et
tous ses déplacements
sa famille l'a accompagné chaque jour et
tout au long de son parcours
mais comme tous les enfants cécile
grandi devient adulte et ses parents
l'ont accompagné là aussi vers l'accès à
la plus grande indépendance possible
pour cela sa mère a passé le relais aux
assistantes de vie sociale depuis sept
mois
brenda assiste cécile à temps plein un
bol d'air temps pour cécile que pour ses
parents d'avancé s'il a toujours vécu
avec nous pour moi il n'a jamais été
question en quelle année dans une
institution allait dans notre vie
c'est le pouviez vivre tout seul ce
serait son grand désir mais bon
actuellement c'est peut-être pas encore
possible et au moins aller dans la vie
avec nous et avec l'accompagnement
qu'elle a à domicile et ben il est
vraiment dans la vie je suis des cours
malheureusement elle ne peut rien faire
tout seul donc elle est accompagnée
toute la journée
mais grâce à ses filles moi je continue
mon travail mon mari aussi et nous ça
nous permet d'être aussi d'avoir notre
vie grâce aux assistantes de vie de
cécile on n'y met pas un mot non on
rentre du lycée donc ces moments où
c'est s'il prend le goûter normalement
prend le thé avec ses parents sociaux
moment des changes c'est moi qui me
servent un frigo je suis prof un jus de
fruit
je lui ai demandé au préalable aux
escales et bob ward langer a calé
choisissent je prends son verre à la
main de fer pour qu'elle puisse être
pour elle pour les puces d'amener tout
seul devoir tout seul
au paille pour qu'elle pose toute seule
et elle m'a demandé elle m'a dit qu'elle
voulait goûter
donc aujourd'hui c'est un peu
particulier parce que sa mère un
rendez-vous et son père rentre tard donc
on est que tout
brenda travaille 35 heures par semaine
elle est relayée par une deuxième avs
employé à mi-temps accompagner une
personne porteuse de handicap exige un
savoir faire et un savoir être
sanctionnée par un diplôme être côtés de
cécile c'est aussi continuer à l'aider à
développer son indépendance j'essaye au
maximum donc d'être à l'écouté s'il ne
pas prendre des décisions pour elle que
ce soit elle qui prennent les décisions
ceci était une jeune femme qui a saisi
namik qui fait partie de l'association
handibou mecs qui étaient d'âge aux
ailettes
elle va aussi souvent au cinéma
j'accompagne aussi dans les sorties
plage
où en ce moment elle aime bien
on va souvent fois par mois au karaoké
elle va aussi voir des spectacles
d'impro des prêtes à faire 15 km
aller-retour la être avs s'est partagé
beaucoup de temps avec la personne qu'on
accompagne brenda est entré dans
l'intimité de la famille graville parce
que c'est quand même avoir quelqu'un
tout le temps à la maison chez vous et
quand même un feeling parce qu'elles
rendent dans notre intime d'abord dans
l'intimité de cécile ce qui est pas
toujours évident et puis dans la nôtre
aussi
en résonance puisque puisque c'est
sylvie dans notre maison c'est
particulier parce que je suis rentré
vraiment dans la vie d'une famille bien
c'est donc cécile habitant chez ses
parents je suis au quotidien
et si et je suis vraiment rentré dans la
vie de tous les jours que ce soit de son
père de sa mère
c'est pas forcément évident il faut
arriver à créer une relation faut garder
une certaine distance comme et être
assez discrète mais tout en s'impliquant
la famille grave il doit accorder sa
confiance à brenda une relation
construite pas à pas plus la confiance
s'installe et plus est s'ils passent de
temps en dehors du cocon familial et
gagnent en autonomie à la rive à te dire
des choses comme ça lui plaît pas quand
ça va pas et tout et nous c'était
vraiment avec nous elle nous dit y'a pas
de problème mais je sais avec thé et
dante il faut que tu arrives même si ça
ça va pas dans leur sens et tout cet
avis et toi six essais importants et moi
c'est quelque chose que j'ai
ressenti au début ils avaient beaucoup
de mal à me dire des choses quand ça
n'allait pas et il a fallu que j'aille
pousser sa force de créer une relation
confiance qu'elle terminait
réchauffement une fois j'ai dû vieillir
mais dis moi là ça va pas vraiment je
passe autant la question à ce que ça va
et c'est comment je fais est ce que sais
tu combien parce qu'elle n'avait pas le
choix de magna a accepté une nouvelle
personne dans sa famille ouvrir les
portes de sa vie privée a été une étape
importante qu'il a fallu franchir pour
moi c'était une intrusion dans mon
intimité j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de mal j'ai vraiment
dû travailler sur moi mon mari aussi
c'est pas lui non basquiat ce qui a fait
c'est que d'abord on n'a pas le choix si
on veut mener ces six là une certaine
indépendance par rapport à nous on était
obligé de passer par là mais moi je
maintenant je suis satisfaite
brenda est une employée est payé pour
ses services
mais grâce à l'implication et au respect
mutuel la relation professionnelle et
affective vécu dans cette famille trouve
un équilibre
alors quand on dit un métier oui oui
c'est un métier mais
magique donc c'est un métier mais en
même temps il ya quand même il ya des
liens qui sont cécile elle a besoin
d'aimer si elle aime pas c abs annie
rapin